Are you guys watching anything else this season?
Or are you guys waiting to see what gets hype? And we'll get one to watch,
uh, what the called one drag priority. That is one direct priority. Yeah.
Weirdest, title. But I watched the trailer on it because I heard so many people,
a lot of people were asking me like, Hey, have you seen the first episode? This,
I was like, that doesn't even sound like a real enemy.
One direct wondering party that that sounds made up.
But then I checked out the tree.
I was like, actually, this kind of looks fire. Yeah.
It's it's too early to tell how it's going to go because I've watched the first
episode about that is it's, it's one of those shows where I'm just like,
I don't even know.
And I mean, it's, it's one of those weird I'll wait, I'll wait. I ask people.
I was like, what's this?
And people just said, just watch it. It feels like a,
like an eco horror show or something like that. Don't like,
Sarah's on my or something or something like that. I'm just,
I'm just throwing out words. I kind of just like.
You could be speaking in tongues right now. What the?
A slight light tatami galaxy vibe to it, you know, like kind of just like,
it's like so strange that it's hard to describe five to it. What I,
what I will say it, it feels like, it feels like Madoka,
Magica directed by Ihara. Um, it's, it's really the you guys.
So you can hire is the director that made Sarah [inaudible], uh,
penguin drum. Um,  what else has he made? What else has he for hire made melee
? What's that magical girl? One day doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. You don't, you've not seen any of his
works
. Right. But he makes a lot of weird stuff and it's I watched the first episode and it's the,
what I will say. I can't really sport
with it because I don't even understand the first episode. You know what I mean? But it's a story that it presents the events of this world out of order. Right? So you get, Oh my God. I'm like
racking my brain to.
Figure out how I can describe it's kind.
Of presented story, like, uh,
like a boogie pot Phantom kind of it's it is very reminiscent of biggie.
I just realized like, if you have no context of what you're talking about,
actually just sounds like you guys are talking about jibberish.
What's the weirdest.
You've watched on away. Just now.
Like a lot of the, when people like, dude, you got to wash this animates.
So it's cool.
On the same vein as serial experiments lane boogie, pop Phantom. I,
I feel like you just, haven't watched.
She wants you put those shows on you're like,
there's no way you could enjoy this without doing like four tabs of acid.
You know what I mean?
Like a lot of shows are like that and then we them with experiments.
But I'd argue that like something like boogie ball Phantom is
I don't really concern myself with it. I mean,
it's something where you have to be in a very specific mood to enjoy it because
it's not something you can just put on and just enjoy it as an insane,
as like a coherent story or something. But what I will say is out of,
because I put my season on video, I watch every,
the first two episodes of like every new anime and out of everything I watched,
it's the one where I watched it didn't know what was going on.
Didn't fully understand it, but I, it stuck with me. You, it, it, it really,
it was really the one where I kept thinking about it after it had ended,
after I'd watched everything else. I was just like, nah, I dunno what it is.
But I keep thinking about wondering priority.
And I don't know what it is exactly about wondering priority that makes me
latch onto it. But there's something, I feel something special.
I get that I kind of, I kind of got that same feeling.
The first time I watched like the first episode of like fully coli, right?
It's like, I dunno what the is happening. Like the student's forehead,
little robot just came out of.
I can give you a play-by-play of what happens in one Dereck.
So this girl there's this like short hooded,
like she wears like a yellow hoodie girl. Um,
the first scene is there a Cicada comes along and starts talking to her and
you're like, okay, whatever cool. She can talk to cicadas.
And then she gets given an egg and then she wonders what to do with this egg.
And then she's sitting on the toilet and then toilet paper starts talking to her
and she's like, yo, what the? And then the egg hatches.
And it turns out that it's a go hatches out the egg.
I think I'll just watch. I don't want to spoil too much,
but that's what was fun. I mean, if, if it, you know,
if the weeks go on and everyone's still like, yeah, it's a good show.
Yeah, sure. I mean, I, from what I can understand about the first episode,
it deals with a lot of themes of depression and suicide.
And it seems like it's a, it,
we get glimpses into our backstory because you know, we get glimpses into,
is, is this a dream world?
Or is this an imagining things or what's kind of going on where we only get
hints at everything. I feel like, again, it's like,
it's kind of like a modern spin on fully coli, right? Cause like fully cool.
It's kind of the same where it's like,
it kind of used it to like absurd imagery to present deeper meanings.
Like I said,
it's way too early to tell what the show is going to be about and how good it
is. But like I said, out of everything, I watch it stuck out to me the most.
That's the one I thought about the most. Um,
but I don't know if you wouldn't want to say the weirdest enemy you've seen.
I don't.
Man, I think you'd have to go through my lace, but.
That was pretty tough that we did that last week.
Or it was pretty some on there that I like,
have you ever watched an anime or a show? And you're just like,
what the did I just watch that made zero sense to me? Like kinda like,
like not in like the vein of like, you know, this was kind of thing,
but like just genuinely the storytelling was so like on the same
lines as the ending of Evangelian or like a, you know,
like a take on concrete or something.
The first time I watched Stephen galleon, I was like, I don't, what the
I was like, Oh, that's how they're going to end it. And like, you know,
some people love finding the deeper meaning in that. And I'm just like,
that was a bit. I'm just gonna get on with my life. I just,
I just really concerned me. I just, I wish I cared, but I, I don't.
And then like maybe a video about my recommendation.
Monkey bar activation. Yeah.
I think I've like programmed my brain to like, just make my life easier.
So like, when I want to just you stuff like that,
but it might drive some people mad. I'm just like monkey, forget monkey,
move on. I just find it funny. How, like,
considering like in a previous episode you said like how you love to challenge
yourself every day. You definitely do not like to challenge yourself on anime,
but like, what is,
what is thinking about the end of Ethan galleon challenging year in any way?
How was that? Well, not necessarily innovative, but like, you know,
something like, you know, like a fully Coolio,
like a take on King where it's like, there are deeper meanings behind
[inaudible]
, here's the thing where you watch it once and you can't get everything. You, you can't enjoy watching it
once, but like, why would that challenge you? There.
Is a challenge as in like, it makes.
You think about its themes more and kind of challenges your,
I guess like perception of how you like consume it.
I guess it's hard to describe like, it, it, it challenges,
challenges off. It's like,
I broke them.
When I watched those things. Right. It's like the deeper meaning everything.
Yeah. More often than not, like I realized that that that's what they're doing.
And I'm like, Oh, okay, cool. And then I'll just, I'll let go.
And Google and I'll be like, what were they trying to say?
But like, don't you like? Cause I find like some.
Enjoyment in kind of watching it and trying to figure it out myself.
You know what I mean? I got a good way to,
it's like unraveling a puzzle by yourself and it's like playing a puzzle game.
Right. You'll you'll give him the pieces and you know,
you're not told what the right answer is,
but it's up to you and it's up to you to unravel it yourself.
It's more like,
it's more like you've given a bunch of pieces and as you're playing around with
the pieces, you realize that it's a puzzle that can't be solved. This is like,
I love map. Right.
Because there is a problem and it is always very clearly defined as such. Right.
It's not logical with like yeah. With stories and all that kind of stuff.
It's I don't like that. I have to figure out what this guy was thinking. Yeah.
Like sometimes I might get a meaning that is not even remotely close to what he
was thinking or the author was thinking when they were writing the thing down.
And to me,
that bothers me that I can just wildly get the answer wrong and I'll never be
corrected. I don't like that. But you assume that that there's a right answer.
Well,
what if he didn't know there was a right answer and that's the problem is that I
don't like that when there's just like an interpretation and it's like,
you just make up what you want. And then it's like, then what?
I would argue that a great story.
Can still entertain you in that aspect of whether it is the actual correct
answer or not. Yeah. I mean, I don't,
I don't really go around like think about it much, I guess. That's I just,
I watch it and I, I like whatever thoughts I have when I finish. I'm like,
all right, cool. Yeah. That's what I'm going to leave with.
And most of the time,
I don't really care to try and find the deeper meaning in it. Um,
and so I think, again, I know this is like, that's such monkey brain.
You can't appreciate fine all et cetera, et cetera.
But I'd say that's even more normal. I, yeah, at the end of the day,
I just don't care.
I think people, me who like actually like trying to find the deeper meaning.
I think we are the minority. Yeah.
I think I'm the minority here because I talk about, I,
the reason I value this so much is because there has been time where like a
piece of media has literally affected sometimes the way I think,
or the way I view life. So, because I know it can have that effect.
I, you know, I try to search it out whenever I can.
Whenever I find that there might be even a glimpse that there might be a deeper
meaning I love going.
I don't know. I just like, I like everything to be efficient.
I like everything to be Don [inaudible].
No.
No, not at all. I like,
I like it when things are very clearly defined the rules. Like this is why,
like, I always, like, I never ever did any artistic subjects in school, right?
Yeah. I don't like how it's all,
it's all like a mess and it's totally interpretation. Yeah.
I like how in math and physics and life, the rules, they make sense.
And you can, you can like take them in and you can like,
like math and physics were my favorite tool. But for me,
it's not fun when I'm like reading a book or something and I'm doing this and
I'm, I'm just being presented with a bunch of nonsense that I'm, uh,
I have to make sense of myself.
I would argue then that if it's a bunch of nonsense without an interpretation,
then that's just a bad story.
Sometimes. Yeah. I mean, sometimes you can make your own,
you can make your own thoughts up from what I was being presented to you and you
just kind of like, cool. Alright, nice.
I came up with what I think happened and then it's like, all right, well,
that's what I think.
I would argue that like the best stories are the ones where you can read it.
Like someone, like you can read it where like,
you don't have to even think about the fact that there might possibly be a
deeper meaning and it's still enjoyable. And at the same time,
people like me that like to look for deeper meanings can also enjoy it.
Like once you get too philosophical, but you know, why,
why do we watch entertainment is to feel things
[inaudible], that's the end. We'll be all right. We, we watch entertaining
to make us feel something, whatever you want to feel, whether it's like adrenaline, sometimes you just want to feel depressed or whatever, you know,
it's and watching something like, for example, the ending episode of the van
galleon I've I remember first time I've watched it. I hated it because
I'm just like, why, why can I not just be given the answer? Why, why is the answer? Not just, you know, being presented to me on like a golden platter,
you know
, that's what I wanted. And then as I grew older and I, it stuck with me and I've rewatched it and I'm just like,
Oh, this is, this is making me feel different things.
Sure. In future, maybe I'll change my mind on it. But right now for me, uh,
like entertainment and media, it's just like,
I just want to relax and thinking is not relaxing.
I just want to get on with it because I'm working so much.
And I just want to do the things I want to do. And to me,
and detainment is purely like a gas stop on my destination. It's like,
let's just stop for a moment and have some fun. Yeah.
I mean, I get that too. Like,
it's not like every pieces of excitement I watch is like mind bending.
Like it's, like I said,
sometimes you just need to be in a very specific mood to enjoy this piece of
media. I'm just like, you know what? I want to feel pretentious right now. Like,
I kind of want to like figure out if this, as a deep opinion.
I, I, when I speak to people who talk like that about the media, they like,
I'm like, you know, part of me is envious because I don't care for that.
But because I think a lot of people are envious of that.
Cause I think when you meet a lot of people,
they'll claim that they can see to find a meaning and all of that.
And most of the time they have no idea. Um, but you know, I don't know.
I'm just completely open with the fact that I'm like, I don't care.
I don't catch a cat. Yeah.
I mean, what I like,
what I don't understand is the other extreme where it's people who can't
seem to enjoy media, unless there is something deeper about it. Like, I,
there are times when I just want to watch a ISA call and just not have to think,
you know what I mean? Yeah.
And I guess it's like the people who like think that every single piece of
entertainment or media has some kind of deeper meaning under it.
You know what I mean? It's like, no, uh, animate review, a non,
non Bre has no deeper meaning. It's just a slice of life. Like just, just chill.
Privileged the problem. It's like,
my only problem is life in life is that my media that I consume doesn't have
enough.
Meaningless. It's like, it's like, Oh my how.
Privileged I used to be where that's a concern, you know what I mean? Like.
That's like the biggest.
First of all, problem where like, you can't get enough fine art.
You know what I mean? That's like,
literally like billionaire probably me off even more. It's like,
you can have your own interpretation for media. Right? That's, that's,
that's very normal for everything.
But what me off is when people project their own meaning
onto this piece of media. And like, like I remember,
I remember where the Saquon Tyson, when, you know, the basement thing happened.
And then there were articles to be like, Oh yeah,
this is promoting Nazi-ism and stuff like that. And I'm just like, Oh, it's not,
Oh God, he gets, he gets to a point where there's a difference between,
you know, analyzing it and interpreting in your own way. And just the,
even when they know the right answer as well, right. It's just like, no, no,
I don't care what the author says. This is what it actually means.
He just doesn't know it yet. It's like, no,
I'm pretty sure if the author said that this is what it means.
That's what a means.
Well, it's, I mean, there's plenty of cases of wildlife.
The orthopedist has control over.
Well, I mean, isn't that like the whole thing with Ava, right?
Where like the frog grip, the death of the author or whatever.